it has often been said that comedians
are just overgrown children I know it's
true that we make faces and crazy sounds
and do just about anything for reaction
but if laughter is the best medicine
then it's time to pay tribute to a comic
genius who has had his own universal
health care plan for over 60 years the
recipient of the Jean Hersholt
Humanitarian Award mister Jerry Lewis
as Jarius said he gets paid for doing
what children are punished for and
though that makes him the world's most
famous overgrown kid he's never
forgotten all those kids who inspire him
in house and he has never stopped giving
back to them jerry has had a huge
influence on my career and the career of
just about every other comic who's
working in movies today but that pales
in comparison to the influence that he's
had for those millions known around the
world as Jerry's kid he is giving back
from one Nutty Professor to another it
is my pleasure and honor to present the
Jean Hersholt Humanitarian Award to mr.
Jerry Lewis
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
thank you so very much for most of my
life I thought that doing good for
someone didn't mean you would receive
commendation for that act of kindness at
least until now this award touches my
heart and the very depth of my soul
because of who the award is from and
those who will benefit the humility I
feel is staggering and I know it'll stay
with me for the rest of my life I thank
you I thank the Academy and to all you
people for the movie business it's such
a joy being a part of you and everything
you do thank you and good night
[Applause]